[Music]
justin bieber performs his classic baby
while celebrating his third wedding
anniversary with wife haley at the met
gala i'm married now so i think things
just become
more adult i guess that may be so but
not so much so that he can't sing a
throwback everybody loves the 27 year
old singer took the met gala stage on
monday night in new york city to perform
a few songs including his 2010 hit baby
[Music]
as well as some of his latest music like
lonely
[Music]
and anyone
thieves seemingly took a page out of kim
kardashian's book rocking a full face
covering for his performance look i'm
having a good time fashion's biggest
night just happened to take place on the
same day the duo got their marriage
license in 2018 and the couple
celebrated in style as justin and haley
walked the met gala red carpet together
for the first time with haley in a
form-fitting black strapless saint
laurent dress she paired with cool
shades i think
that is a big
show of confidence to be able to be like
this is who i am take it or leave it as
for justin he donned his own fashion
house in this sleek wide-legged suit
from la maison drew a branch of his drew
house label along with a pair of
decorated nikes with hayley and their
pup oscar's names on them the biebers
dished on their looks to vogue before
heading into the soiree both of us love
fashion and we love being able to get
dressed up and collaborate with cool
designers and you know for him being
able to come up with this and debut this
really cool suit the model also shared
some sweet snaps together on her
instagram story one from the red carpet
and one of her wearing a white bathrobe
with justin holding her tight he's
really funny we have a good time
together
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
he's a good part and
i love him happy third anniversary to
justin and haley one of the most stylish
couples in hollywood
[Music]